here's your quiz
because in the book you get in the book
the way i wrote it out was that there's
there's a scale basically so you kind of
put yourself
on the scale okay between the two so
saver
versus spender where are you on the
scale me yep oh spinner
yep which i think is probably surprising
for some people everyone just assumes
and me too they're like oh you love you
teach about money so
you love to save and i'm like i don't
love to save
winston is a saver and sharon's a saver
naturally now i'm a good saver
because i've learned that it is the
shortest
method to spend more
and to be more generous yep i can't i
can't give money away if i'm broke
and i'm like you too i lean way more on
the spender and again extremes on both
on all these scales can be unhealthy so
again the the the moderation is key but
you lean one way or the other okay
scarcity versus abundance abundance
me too yeah are we gonna be the same
person safety versus status and what
this is
is meaning the why you want to why do
you want to win with money for some
people it's completely out of safety i
don't have to worry about it it's there
i'm okay some people want it in order to
live a fun life to go on vacation so
status isn't bad i feel like some people
read this status is not bad there's an
unhealthy version of it
but it's so that i can enjoy life go on
vacation maybe drive a fun car
like i want to use it for things in my
life versus it just being there
that i'm okay but so that would often be
the safety would be the
saver and the status would be the
spender wouldn't sometimes always i mean
i think this could be
the opposite mm-hmm are you more safe
than me oh definitely status definitely
me too
okay quality oh versus quantity
quality okay i'm quantity
i would rather have like 20 pairs of
earrings so you're like you get like ten
dollars sucked into the costco
22 pounds of peanut butter thing yes i
love
yes i like having more stuff versus like
one nice pair of shoes i'd rather have
ten
that are like okay yep that i have to
really choices
but you like quality you'll research and
buy the best of the best even if it's
just one thing
just have the one i've got a pair of
cowboy boots that i have had since
college
but they are top line i mean i've resold
them three times
yeah but they're they're not only are
they broken in and they're perfect but
obviously they had the ability to
last 30 some odd years that's pretty
good so they were
quality boots and you know so that's
fine and i'd rather wear them than new
ones because i don't
want to break them uh when you spend
money is it more on experiences or
things i do both i don't know i'm
probably in the middle on that one
okay you're an experienced girl oh yeah
all the way no question
give me a nice dinner out give me a
vacation go to the zoo with the kids
like i'll go i want to go do stuff
versus having like a thing
yeah your mom's is on things yeah no she
does both though because she's like i
need a vacation
y'all can do both yeah all right we all
can't do both all right
no but this was a good one for i'll say
for me and winston because for the first
probably two or three years of our
marriage even when we did our budget and
all this
i just valued our out to eat category i
was like i love going out to eat
and he always if we went especially at
the beginning of marriage
it's like i'll just get a water and i'm
like get a drink have a drink like it's
fine like
he's like no no it's so expensive like
no it's fine it's fine i'm like oh my
goodness
but i enjoy that whole experience where
he again would buy something and i'm
like
why did you buy that like like it made
no sense yeah but finally when we had
the communication round and i pinpointed
it i was like
oh that your value around where you
spend your money on
that's what it is yeah okay planned
giving versus spontaneous giving
well this is a brain versus a a natural
my natural
brain versus heart yeah my my natural
response is spontaneous
yep and yet the vast majority of our
giving is very planned
we even plan our spontaneity i mean it's
like
so we have categories in the ramsey
family foundation that's just money so
it's just sitting there so if something
comes up we can you know a single mom
needs some help with something that
you know pops up uh we had a uh
we had an opportunity through uh the
legal system to help a family that was
messed up beyond belief the other day
and we you know we had the money so we'd
plan to be able to be
so it's i don't know but it's yeah but
personally just walking up and giving
somebody some you know
i leave a large tip uh that for me so
it's spawn
spontaneous spontaneous and i guess it
is for spontaneous giving yeah mine's
spontaneous too
i'll hear like this you know some
amazing organization they're doing
and i'm like real gift to you we'll give
to you for the rest of our lives
because i'm like yes i just want to help
and like it's amazing until i see
someone else
yeah that's it i know right yeah so
those are
the seven money tendencies as part of
the book and breaking down the
the good the bad the ugly of each one
some roadblocks that could be ahead for
you depending on where you lean on the
scale
but having those in the back of your
mind helps you understand this is
why i do some things i do with money
what we have known at ramsey and what
you've really
clarified and put not put a lot of work
around is that
the biggest obstacle between where you
are today
and becoming wealthy is not
opportunity it's not your income it's
you controlling you
and you understanding you helps you
control you
so that you can win the problem with my
money is the person in my mirror we've
said that for years
and what you're doing here is to say
okay if i'm gonna be a nerd i need to be
a healthy
nerd that way i don't kill my free
spirit
that i'm married to you know and run
them into the dirt and you
turn dave ramsey's name into a cuss word
and all those kinds of things and so
know yourself know your money